[Music]
why hello there you sexy monkey fluffer
it's a new month which means even more
video games want to your hard-earned
cash just in time for the holiday season
2019 November has over 30 games dropping
so I've looked over them and selected
nine which deserve a little more
attention like usual if you'd like me to
play any of these games just let me know
I'm happy to waste my money on any video
game you like anyway if you're ready
let's do this I have to start with death
stranding after years of intrigue and
downright weird promotion we will
finally see a Hideo Kojima's first game
after leaving Konami death stranding is
a confusing thing to explain we've seen
a man urinating on the ground we've seen
him carry mummified bodies on his back
remember the time he used the magic
ladder to cross a gorge that that was
that was fun we've also seen babies in
brine filled jars we've seen a man
peeing on the ground links to other
dimensions monsters giants a man
urinating on the ground and lunchtime
for this femme fatale but even though
it's a complete mind here's what we do
know though death stranding is an
open-world action game in which we play
a Sam Bridges who is a delivery man
tasked with bringing survivors of the
seemingly post-apocalyptic America back
together and simultaneously going
coast-to-coast to rescue Emily the next
president of the USA who forced some
unknown reason can't age you know what
we should just wait a few days because
the first round of reviews are coming
very soon on November the 1st so let's
not try and pick it just yet be prepared
for mind-bending storytelling if I'm
honest I'm expecting a masterpiece of a
game but something most casual gamers
will struggle to get into but here's a
question does all this unknowing around
the game interest you or make you turn
and run away the thing which sold me
I've already told you a few times the
man on the grass I love its death
stranding releases exclusively on ps4 on
November the 8th oh and just as I was
clicking upload on this video we have
finally got confirmation that death
stranding will indeed be coming to the
PC but not until next year so 2020 but
hey that's still impressive for a game
touted as a ps4 exclusive ok back to the
video
[Music]
what's your current feeling about EI hmm
yeah I agree if you love them or hate
them the distrust many players have may
soon be a thing of the past
hear me out with this one this is Star
Wars Jedi fallen order a single-player
story focused action-adventure title
without any loot boxes or other EA
predatory tactics I know I'm shocked too
in terms of the story of Jedi fallen
order it takes place shortly after order
66
yeah when all the baby Jedi's were
motorized by a terrible actor we now
fill the Bilt's of Cal Justice a Jedi
Padawan who has somehow survived this
Massacre and escaped but does he keep
his identity hidden hello he uses the
Force in the open and now the entire
Empire is coming for him
happy days the combat feels awesome and
has all the Flair you expect from a Star
Wars game with elements of RPG entwined
like the ability to purchase upgrades
such as throwing your lightsaber
mid-battle cool isn't it
a lot of inspiration has come from the
dark souls franchise with battles taking
into account defensive play with a gauge
for stamina you know for blocking and
deflecting and a general need to time
strikes to win battles continuing the
Dark Souls feel fallen order uses
meditation points replicating bomb fires
as a new spawn point after death and
it's also a place to buy those upgrades
fallen order also has many puzzles like
those found in Tomb Raider and wall
running like the days of prince of
persia all the memories many elements
from lots of great games have been
incorporated here making this a far
deeper game than most people realize
traveling around the galaxy and taking
on brand new enemy types created
especially for this game but also all
the law is a dear to and expanded on
here Star Wars Jedi fallen order has me
hugely interested but how do you feel
about it November 15th we get our grubby
hands on it on ps4 Xbox one and PC
[Music]
how old do you think the Need for Speed
series is well prepare for this it's 25
years old and to commemorate that is
need for speed heat the 24th game in the
series racing around an open world Miami
Florida in which we can switch between
day and night to change up races heat
has a story campaign which pits us
against the city's best races and our
city racing is illegal you'll have
regular brushes with the law and of
course some of those cops are dirty and
corrupt making us the underdog antihero
of this story is kinda like the fast and
furious movies the old ones
not not the the recent one you know what
I mean heat is filled with so many cars
with so many customization options and
speaking of customization we can now
wear adidas socks lovely what a world we
live in the name heat also impacts
gameplay as our heat level rises the
cops become more heavy-handed in their
pursuit of you adding much more risk
reward so don't you dare get busted need
for speed heat drops on November 8th on
ps4 Xbox one and PC
oh look pink socks hell yeah brother
20 years ago a defining game released
Shenmue an action-adventure game with
elements of open-world and the day/night
cycle never seen before in video games
I mean shops opened and closed at
certain times in the day 20 years later
all those things are now commonplace and
back in the Dreamcast days these were
cutting-edge now Shenmue 3 is about to
release which puts us back in the shoes
of Ryo Hazuki a teenager from Japan who
watched his father die in battle with a
bad guy called lundi our life's mission
is to hunt that guy down and to cut a
long story short ryo didn't manage to do
this in the two previous games but
slowly unveiled the hidden story of his
father's past while simultaneously
paying his bills and making a living
yeah you get a job in these games
learning new martial art moves to
strengthen his cause will Shenmue 3
finally let Ryo have his vengeance my
guess is no will likely have to wait
another 20 years for that one Shenmue 3
releases on ps4 and PC on November the
20th other releases this month include a
brand new Pokemon game for you Nintendo
switch players pokemon sword and shield
you must know the Pokemon concept by now
catch a Pokemon in the wild and then
battle are the trainers at gyms okay
full transparency here I have never
played a Pokemon game is sword and
shield a good starting point I think I'm
gonna buy one and why is there two
versions of this game this doesn't make
any sense I'm so confused right now
Nintendo please help me out
over on the PC you guys finally get your
hands on Red Dead Redemption 2 which is
already a year old Wow time flies
the PC Edition will definitely be the
must nuts in terms of visuals but
personally I can't wait to see what the
modding community does to this game it's
gonna look even more breathtaking than
it already does here's a game which has
a great deal of potential sniper ghost
Warrior contracts I say potentially
because the previous games didn't live
up to expectations so we're all a little
weary now this is the fifth game in the
series let's see if they get it right
this time
sniper games are notoriously difficult
to create
but contracts looks to be the most
impressive sniper ghost Warrior game
shelling movement and tactical sniping
with that good old bullet time gone a
Kanak we all love and hit Man esque
level design on November 22nd you can
unleash your inner assassin on ps4 Xbox
and PC fingers crossed this is the one
which gets this series up and going
[Music]
another gaming franchise which continues
to release year upon year is just dance
this time is the 2020 version which
releases on ps4 switch Xbox one and get
this it releases on Nintendo Wii who'd
have thought that in 2019 with over 500
tracks to dance to and 40 current chart
hits this series refuses to stop come on
be serious have you ever played Just
Dance how much of an idiot did you look
I actually want to play this again now
November 5th I can't wait
and here's a strange one to end on
blacks add under the skin I mean look at
it you play as a Panther detective
looking into a murder case if you've
never heard of blacks add it's a Spanish
comic book published by a French
publisher based in New York City and is
now an english-speaking video game it's
good to see the world getting on like
this the characters as you can see are
all animals with great attention made to
replicate their real-life
characteristics such as gorillas tend to
be fighters huge hulking things whereas
bloodhounds and other types of dogs tend
to represent the police it uses
stereotypes to quickly force us to jump
to conclusions
black sad is a noir game which means it
may be a little depressing think of it
like a blend of heavy rain and la Noir
in terms of feel no our games never fill
you with happiness but that's part of
that genre if you'd like to try this
this unique game comes out on November
the 5th so there we have it new games
for November 2019 what are you grabbing
this month I have to get my hands on
death stranding to understand that
madness and Jedi fallen order looks damn
good too
come on EA can you bring this back but
what about you what are you grabbing
this month please let me know in the
comments I'd love to know I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade if you got this far
you should totally follow me on Twitter
don't you appreciate it
I'm Adam granade over there anyway it's
been a pleasure I shall see you all next
time peace out monkey floppers
[Music]